est-il possible
de rentrer dans un monde
dominé par les grandes multinationales
les géants de la technologie de notre
ère
et tu as une femme
africaine
est-il possible
je pense que oui
je suis je suis l'exemple parfaite de
cela
je suis une femme
je suis mère
passionné de technologie
qui serait en chemin
dans un secteur
dominé par les géants
par les hommes
je vais vous raconter une petite
histoire
une petite histoire qui a changé toute
ma vie
et c'est la deuxième fois que je la
raconte
alors
qu'on fasse beau
est né
suite à une
discrimination une injustice
que j'ai subi moi-même
je travaillais pour une multinationale
une grosse multinationale
où j'étais très impliquée
franchement j'aimais bien mon boulot
j'étais à fond parce que je me donnais
koriane pour pouvoir répondre mes
objectifs
et j'ai subi
une injustice de mon patron je vais
faire le nom de la multinationale on va
pas faire de pur pour eux
et
quand j'ai subi ça en justice je me suis
promise de le faire regretter
je lui ai dit en espagnol
je lui ai dit en gros tout est le
pierres
en gros ça signifie c'est toi qui perds
moi je veux plus que tout ce que tu
crois je veux plus que tout ce que tu
penses
et six mois après
qu'on fasse
beaucoup beaucoup attristé au début
j'étais très pénible mais avec avec le
recul avec le recul je le remercie avec
le recul je le remercie parce qu'il a
réussi à réveiller cette force à moi il
a réussi à me dire que tu peux le faire
donc il m'a challengé ça m'a permis de
réfléchir sur une fois ça m'a permis de
me mettre
en question et de lui de lui montrer que
je vaux plus que lui ce que lui croit en
fait donc je le remercie
parce qu'il m'a il m'a appris ce que
c'est que la persévérance et le refus
surtout d'abandonner
alors kumfabo
bah je pense que la majorité ici dans la
salle savent ce que c'est que kumfabo
est né en 2016
de communication créer une marque
africaine qui ne représente et avec
laquelle nous nous identifions
alors
grâce aux applications que nous avons
développées pour accompagner le
consommateur africain dans sa vie
quotidienne
dans le domaine de la de la santé de
l'arc urinaire du mobile banking donc on
touche un peu tous les domaines pour
pouvoir vraiment mettre le consommateur
africain au centre de la marque
je vais vous
rappeler une citation
de Napoléon Hill que j'adore
que je me suis intériorisée et que j'ai
expérimenté également
quand il dit tout ce à quoi l'homme
pense et crois peut se réaliser cette
citation me rentre dans les veines j'y
crois parce que je l'expérimenté
tous ceux à quoi l'homme pense et croit
peut se réaliser pour moi c'est super
fort ça rentre dans mes veines
et je l'ai intériorisé je me le répète
chaque fois que j'ai j'ai des petits
soucis que j'ai des difficultés je me
rappelle je me dis je peux le faire
et on n'a pas que des succès enfin moi
j'ai eu beaucoup de désillusions
énormément
des doutes
des échecs passagères
c'est normal
c'est le process que nous souvent c'est
le process que en tout cas ceux qui
embrassent le métier de
l'entrepreneuriat ils vont tous finir
par passer manger énormément de doutes
j'ai des doutes et c'est impression
constante de perdre mon temps on
l'expérimente tous un moment donné de
notre développement entrepreneurial on
arrive tout à l'expérimenter
et imaginez une femme dans ce milieu qui
est très masculin en milieu de
multinationale je veux dire des loups
des grands de ce monde et toi une petite
femme tu viens de nulle part tu dis au
lait je suis là je parle faire je veux
pas faire parler de moi aussi je vais
vous dire ce que je fais et pourquoi pas
donc au début au début de kufo la
majorité des gens pensaient que je t'ai
la commerciale de kumfabo que je t'ai
juste
la représentante de la marque parce
qu'il y avait beaucoup de gens qui
concevaient pas au fait que la la
conceptive soit une femme
et je l'ai vécu beaucoup enfin dans Les
Colocs la majorité où j'insiste je suis
presque la seule femme et tous mes
collègues c'est des hommes et au début
on te prend pas au sérieux donc tu es
obligé de t'affirmer tu es obligé c'est
pourquoi on dit ces femmes qui sont dans
ce milieu elles sont un peu dures je
pense pas qu'elle soit dures c'est le
milieu au fait qui qui fait ça parce que
quand tu viens il faut vraiment on te
prend pas beaucoup sur eux on dit bon
elle est un peu capricieuse mais après
ça va lui passer ça va pas ça va pas le
faire donc tu es obligé de travailler
deux fois plus qu'un homme dont tu te
mets toi même la pression parce que tu
as fait tu as pas droit à l'échec parce
que nous même en tant que femme nous
nous mettons énormément la pression on
se dit quand tu tu tu tu comment quand
tu te plantes on dira ben toute façon
elle a laisse planter c'était prédestiné
donc on se met la pression et c'est pas
normal on a tous besoin de se planter on
a tous besoin de se faire des erreurs et
c'est à travers ses erreurs qu'on
s'améliore moi je dis enfin il faut
avoir cet homme cette mentalité
anglo-saxonne qui dit
l'échec n'est pas une fin en soi voilà
quand on quand on échec quand on a
des obstacles c'est parce que le plan a
été mal fait ici on arrive à se rebondir
faut avoir cette mentalité
anglaise saxonne enfin Thomas Edison
pour pouvoir faire une ampoule il a fait
plus de 10 mes échecs imagine que Thomas
séduction qui fait 10000 échecs et toi
tu abandonnes en 4 ans donc moi je suis
une personne extrêmement positive je
suis très positive et
à fond la persévérance aussi faut faire
un travail sur soi pour être persévérant
donc on a besoin de on peut jamais faire
carrière tout seul on peut jamais être
savant tout seul toute façon on sait pas
tout seul moi je suis pas je suis pas
j'ai pas fait de suite d'un génial donc
je peux pas coder je peux pas faire en
code je peux pas je sais pas le faire
donc j'ai besoin des autres j'ai besoin
d'aller vers les autres même si j'ai des
idées je planifie tout mais j'ai besoin
de l'expertise j'ai besoin de savoir
faire des autres pour pouvoir aller de
l'avant
je dors comme ça bon
je mange comme ça
je me réveille comme ça beau ma vie
tourne autour de kumfabo
je suis amoureuse de kumfabo
en gros je suis obsessionnée par kumfabo
et c'est tant mieux pour moi parce que
ça me permet de rester focus sur mon
projet pour atteindre nos objectifs et
aller au-delà de la vision que nous nous
sommes fixés c'est cela en fait
avoir une idée c'est très bon le départ
de toute chose de toute grande chose de
des grandes choses de ce monde c'est
d'avoir déjà une idée
matérialiser l'idée mais je pense que
l'idée
l'idée sera 10% mais la passion c'est ça
en fait
la passion c'est
c'est 90% pour la chose il faut avoir la
passion parce que quand on a pas la
passion
adéquat on est plus apte abandonné donc
je disais qu'on a besoin d'aller vers
les autres on a besoin du
professionnalisme des autres on a besoin
de travailler avec les autres je
confonds ce que nous nous appliquons
c'est le concept du cerveau collectif
oui pour profiter de l'expertise de
chacun pour pouvoir apporter en plus à
l'entreprise en plus à la start-up en
plus à l'idée tout seul on va jamais
faire carrière on a besoin des coachs
également parce que à l'entrepreneuriat
surtout dans le numérique il faut avoir
un mental d'acier cette persévérance il
y a un moment donné on craque moi je
craque des fois je pleure je suis
quelqu'un j'aime pas pleurer devant les
gens parce que j'aime pas avoir la pitié
des gens enfin même devant mon mari mes
proches ils me voient jamais pleurer
donc je pleure dans mon coin ça me
permet de me libérer mais après je vais
avoir mon coach on a tous besoin d'un
coach on a besoin de quelqu'un qui nous
motive qui nous propulse
qui nous disent que nous enfin en gros
tout le balai quelqu'un qui te dit tu
peux le faire tu tu vas au mieux tu peux
le faire plus que ça
tu es extraordinaire c'est ça en fait on
a besoin de ses côtes de vie qui forge
notre mental on peut pas se passer de
ces gens-là parce qu'à un moment donné
nous sommes pas des à superwomanes nous
sommes des êtres humains à un moment
donné vu les difficultés que nous avons
en craque et c'est normal de craquer
parce que ça te permet de te remettre en
question
et quand je parle de technologie c'est
vrai le monde c'est la technologie c'est
le futur du monde c'est l'avenir donc un
brassis métier c'est embrasser l'avenir
et malheureusement nous constatons qu'il
y a beaucoup de brèches
c'est un métier c'est un secteur qui est
beaucoup
masculin il y a pas beaucoup de femmes
c'est vrai ces dernières années
on arrive à voir je connais énormément
de femmes qui sont en train de faire
changer les choses qui sont en train de
de fermer cette brèche cette grosse
pêche soit en train de de se battre mes
sœurs pour pour faire cette différence
mais on est encore loin de la parité
voilà le secteur est très très masculin
on a besoin de nos sœurs on a besoin
d'inspirer nos filles nos petites sœurs
et quand elles nous voient elles disent
je peux le faire moi aussi moi quand
j'étais petit je voulais être avocate
voilà technologie c'était pas ma tasse
de thé ce qui m'a amené déjà toute
petite je savais ce que je voulais faire
parce que toute petite je voulais être
avocate qui m'amène à faire des études
de droit donc technologie c'était pas du
tout mon truc entrepreneuriat nada ça
c'est venu après
donc en grandissant j'ai eu des idées ça
a changé j'ai eu d'autres passions qui
étaient la technologie l'innovation et
je me suis scotché sur ça et donc nous
on a la chance c'est pourquoi il faut
pas rester dans l'ombre il y a beaucoup
de gens qui qui disent fadima elle est
très exposée je m'en fous je suis
exposée oui je veux que la petite fille
que ma petite sœur qu'elle sache que
j'existe parce que ça les permettrait de
enfin elles peuvent trouver un modèle à
moi je peux les inspirer les influencer
embrasser ce métier c'est ce que nous
voulons vaut plus de voix masculine
là-bas qui disent olé Ameno collègues
hommes salut monsieur nous sommes là on
peut innover et mieux encore
si moi je l'ai fait
c'est que tout le monde peut le faire
parce que je t'ai pas du tout près des
ciné à cela
tout le monde peut le faire il faut
juste avoir un plan
je suis quelqu'un de extrêmement têtu je
suis très très têtu
et quand je veux quand je me fixe des
objectifs
je vais les attendre coûte que coûte
vaille que vaille
et mes collaborateurs ils savent je suis
un peu obsessionnée je suis un peu c'est
difficile de travailler avec quelqu'un
qui est très obsessionné parce que des
fois elle se perd dans son obsession et
tout donc vraiment c'est une ambiance de
familiarité d'amitié je suis pas
habituée au vous par exemple le fait de
vous voyez les gens donc tout le monde
dans l'équipe m'appelle fady ça me gêne
pas ça c'est mon nom donc le fait de de
vous de la solennité je suis pas
beaucoup habitué à ça mais bon on
s'habitue petit à petit donc c'est
vraiment
un cerveau collectif qui travaille
ensemble des ingénieurs des développeurs
des des infographes des des
metteurs en salle donc on a toute une
équipe qui est là qui vraiment met
son savoir-faire au service du projet et
c'est tant mieux pour moi parce que ça
permet d'aller de l'avant tout n'est pas
rose on a beaucoup beaucoup de
difficultés et maintenant que je vous
parle là là où je suis on a beaucoup de
difficultés oui mais c'est des
challenges ça peut surpasser parce que
du moment où on sort pas de notre cadre
on respecte notre cadre moi je n'ai pas
de plan B
peut-être c'est une horreur je sais pas
mais j'ai pas de plan B donc j'ai un
plan a alors j'ai intérêt que mon plan a
fonctionne parce que si mon plan à froid
c'est mort donc j'ai pas intérêt que ça
foire je me focus sur le plan a bon je
vais conclure en disant
n'ayez pas peur
personne ne savait on apprend tout ça
prend le fait de parler devant les gens
ça s'apprend
le fait d'être éloquent d'être
charismatique ça s'apprend c'est vrai
d'autres ont plus de charisme que
d'autres mais tout ça prend dans la vie
tout ça prend n'est pas avec ça
s'apprend donc n'ayez pas peur d'aller
vers les autres parler de ce que vous
faisez parler de votre projet parlez
n'ayez pas peur si moi j'avais peur de
parler de kung-fu personne ne connaîtra
je serai pas là aujourd'hui en train de
vous parler de kumfabo donc innover
n'abandonnez jamais persévérer
si je l'ai fait vous pouvez le faire je
vous remercie
merci